Eventually our ADD produces a result, and when that happens we will broadcast
it. The broadcast of the result happens exactly as before in Tomasulo algorithm,
except that the tag we carry for the result is the ROB entry,
not the reservation station number. Because we have already freed
the reservation station. So what we do is we now broadcast, the tag of
ROB6 with a value, let's say, 15. Just like with Tomasulo's algorithm,
this value, and the tag are now, given to the reservation stations.
And they normally capture the result based on the tag, as before. This result is
now broadcast to the reservation stations. And they capture this result if,
if they need it. And those that need the result of this instruction will capture
the value 15 just like, we did in Tomasulo's algorithm. So this has not changed.
Without the ROB, we would now also capture this result in the register.
And update the RAT to point to that register. With the ROB,
we don't want to write to the register yet, so we write to the ROB instead.
So these broadcast value now goes to the ROB, and we write 15 here and
mark the instruction as done. Also. The result of the instruction,
is not going to be in the registers. So, we do not update the RAT, to point to
the registers. In fact, the RAT is still pointing to the correct place.
The result of the instruction is in the ROB now. So, we don't do this here.
After broadcasting its result, the instruction would be completed,
in Tomasulo's algorithm. With the ROB. We're still not done with it.
Yes, we have computed the result and logged the computation as done, but
we have not deposited this result in the registers. For
that there is an additional step, called commit. To commit this instruction,
we must first commit all of the previous instructions. So each cycle,
we test whether the next instruction at the commit point is done. In which case,
the commit point can move on and commit this instruction. So eventually,
the commit point will reach here. And now, we will
test whether this instruction is done, find out that it's done, and commit it.
The committing of the instruction, consists of actually taking this value, 15,
and writing it to the register that the instruction is supposed to write to.
In this case R1. So, 15 will be retained here. And also,
we need to update the RAT, because it's pointing to the entry ROB6, that entry
will be freed after we commit this instruction. So instead of pointing to ROB6,
now we can point to R1. So really, the updating of the RAT for
writing to the register, has moved from the broadcast time to the commit time,
because that's when we are actually updating the registers. And
after committing this instruction, the commit point will move, even further, so
that the next instruction to commit will be here, and that completes our
reorder buffer processor step by step, for one instruction. As you can see,
many other things, are happening exactly the same as in Tomasulo's algorithm.
Some of the things have changed, like point the RAT to the ROB entry instead of
the reservation station. Writing to the ROB, on broadcast instead of
the register file. And also we have added, a step here for committing.
Also we can free the reservation station on dispatch, not on broadcast. And
finally, we need a new step for actually committing the instruction.